normalement c'est les champignons qui
sentent loggia belz ils sentent le
chlore
la forêt domaniale de boulogne entre
blois chambord est un lieu réputé pour
ses cueillettes de champignons
encore faut-il en connaître les coins
propice aux cèpes ou coulemelles ou à
gérone pour cela maurice est l'un des
meilleurs guides alors ça on n'appelle
pas ça un cèpe on appelle ça un bol et
tout ce qui a de la mousse en dessous
bollée parce que l'appellation cep est
vraiment
restreinte elle concerne quatre
champignons 4 ball est parmi les
meilleurs
aujourd'hui c'est une trentaine
d'amateurs plus ou moins éclairés qui
découvre les trésors mycologique de la
forêt avec une grande curiosité et un
expert on a vu qu'ils organisent ça
c'est gratuit donc on espère apprendre
de plein de choses après peut-être aussi
les champignons qu'on connaissait pas
avant qu'on ramassait pas parce qu'on
les connaît pas par exemple toxiques à
sion connaît
justement l'excitation de la cueillette
ne doit pas faire oublier la nécessaire
prudence
avant la fin de l'été plus de 300
intoxication été enregistrés en france
dont trois mortels
il y en a une ou deux découle des
lépiotes qui sont effectivement
comestibles mais il y en a au moins une
dizaine qui sont mortels pour mettre en
garde le public les association
mycologique multiplie les événements
dans ce salon de l'automne par exemple
en dispense conseils et alerte et à
manger que ce que vous connaissez
absolument extrêmement bien et surtout
faire en sorte aussi que la personne qui
cuisine ça soit un mycologue parce que
c'est souvent au moment de la
préparation qu'on se rend compte qu'il
ya un intrus dans la récolte et moi j'ai
eu même des amis qui connaissait bien
les champignons qu'ils se sont rendus
compte au dernier moment qu'il y avait
un champignon mortel dont l'eau quoi
l'amanite phalloïde 99% des cas
d'intoxication vous vous rendez compte
que vous êtes malade au bout de 48
heures 72 heures vous avez déjà la
moitié du foie qui est liquéfié
en respectant scrupuleusement ses
recommandations votre sortie en forêt
sera non seulement sans risque mais
aussi gastronomiquement bénéfique